in the lobby of Ramsey solutions up JV
and Ashley are with us hey guys how are
you hi we're great folks where you guys
from we're from California
what part let's ban us where let's ban
us okay what's that near help me it's
not really near anything it's an hour
and a half from San Jose an hour and
half from Fresno okay very cool well
welcome to Nashville thank you thanks
for coming you're here to do your debt
free scream how much have you paid off
one hundred six thousand all right and
how long did that take you five and a
half months five and a half yes
all right very cool and during that time
your range of income household income
start at ninety thousand mm-hmm and she
worked half of last year so it ended up
at one hundred thirty five thousand okay
cool
so actually you got a job in the middle
of this it did yeah okay very cool what
do you do I'm a physical therapist cool
and Jamie what do you do I'm an engineer
all right good so you guys are making
great money what kind of debt was the
hundred and sixty thousand dollars that
was our house paid off your house yeah
you guys aren't old enough to have a
perhaps you're so weird I love it way to
go you guys hey how old are you - I'm 26
oh my gosh 30 oh my gosh yeah well in
California no less what is this house
worth um now it's worth around 300,000
twenty-six years old I love you you're
awesome this is so very cool how long
have y'all been married 2012 December so
four years so what happened
Oh so you started on this b4 no you
start on this just for having half
months ago so what are some five and a
half months ago that made you just go
into high gear here and like this cuz I
mean you know that your friends are
doing this none um I graduated with my
doctorate so okay and that that's when
you started when you started to work you
said okay we're gonna take all my money
that I'm making a handsome and throw it
at the house was that
the point oh yeah we had decided to do
that before I graduated but we did your
plan and saved up just while I was in
school so we had some money to throw out
of thin and then from there we just cash
flowed and put a lot of money on it I
love it I love it so whose idea was this
so you don't have to talk one of you
into the other one and that kind of
thing and but you've been married
cooking along here three three and a
half years and what you just looked up
and saw that you were gonna make the
graduation it's happening there it is in
the I can reach over there and touch it
so let's do this is that what happened
or well tell me the story so while I was
in school I wanted to pay extra but it's
like no let's say while you're in school
make sure you get done and so I
graduated in May of last year and then I
had to get through the licensure and
everything like that so I got a job in
July and then we just started throwing
at it so you wisely said we're not we're
gonna make sure we get enough money with
no student loan that finished school
right yeah even though she's wanting to
go ahead and do this she so you guys
were itching to do this before we were
you just raised by smart parents I mean
what causes there's a 26 and 30 years
old yeah so my parents I have awesome
parents they did not hide their mistakes
from me so that's one word of advice to
parents even if you did it wrong your
kids can learn from that and they just
always told me you know don't go into
debt we started our marriage in debt and
it sucks so just don't go into debt and
so neither of us have me debt and we
bought our house reasonable mortgage and
decided we just wanted to pay it off as
fast as we could so that we didn't have
to deal with it what about you Jamie
what was your background um my parents
raised me smart just don't spend money
you don't have
and you're an engineer so yeah this this
money nerd stuff comes natural right
money go towards interest I really don't
like that
you guys are gonna be so rich it's gonna
be crazy you're gonna be able to be so
generous it's gonna be so crazy
you're gonna completely change your
whole family tree your parents must be
jumping up and down yeah they're pretty
excited they are well they should be
they should be very proud of you I am
I'm very proud of you you guys are
heroes water yeah oh you guys this is if
we kick it off we can just get oh just a
couple of your generation to do this and
a few of Marmion we're coming in here
with paid off houses by the hundred
thirty thirty-five years old
I'm seeing it more and more it's it's a
trend in the last really year and a half
on the debt free screams that we've seen
it but it's just something is making you
guys believe you can do this and then
you go do it yeah there was there's a
story before this we had already decided
we'd paid off but in my last internship
with school I was just observing one of
therapists working with the patient this
vision was like in his nineties oh how
long have you been living here how long
have been in your house and he goes well
you know I just paid it off last month
and the therapist said oh so you've been
in it 30 years Wow and I just don't want
my life measured by how long I have debt
that's just a horrible way to measure
your life oh it was just another
encouragement now you're sitting in a
$300,000 paid off home making 135,000 at
26 and 30 years old
you guys are impressive absolutely
impressive
Wow Wow Wow all right so there's a 25 or
a 24 year old version of you out there
listening right now what do you tell
them that they can know that they have
to do to have a paid off house by the
time they're old like you know card
don't take out student loans do what say
it again work hard and don't take out
student loans okay hey see you gotta
have goals not just the goal for paying
off the house but specific goals for
after that you know we have our goals of
retirement and our goals of travel and
we had specific things laid out written
down it's not a goal until you write it
down so just have a reason besides just
oh you gotta have a reason I can see why
you're where you are you're impressive
very cool
very very cool there's hope America
there's JV and Ashley's out there oh my
gosh you're awesome
alright JV and Ashley from California a
hundred and six thousand dollars paid
off in five and a half months making 92
now 135 in their debt-free house and
everything count it down let's say a
debt free scream very very well done man
that's amazing
now if you're 55 and you were listening
to that does that mean it's too late for
you because they did it at 26 no it
should be your inspiration to get up off
your butt and do it before you're 90 it
just means you can do it that's what it
means if they can do it you can do it
did you notice what they did they did
not buy an expensive house a $300,000
house in California is an inexpensive
house you know that right and they
bought an inexpensive home so that they
could pay it off because their goal of
having it debt-free was right in front
of their face the whole time so they
didn't go lease a car that they couldn't
afford have a student loan that's been
around so long they think it's a pet
they didn't have master card American
distress and discovered bondage coming
out their ears they weren't going on
vacations and rest going to restaurants
they couldn't afford they had a goal in
front of them and now they can do
anything new and a you know you can do
135 thousand dollars a year when you
don't have even a house payment you
become wealthy that's what you do yeah
they'll be able to give they'll be able
to give away more than any two or three
of you put together that don't go do
what they've done if you go live normal
they're gonna give away easily five or
ten times what the average person gives
away what they're being able to have
what kind of outrageous generosity you
can do making that kind of money you're
so free
you're so completely free and you can do
this stuff you list your debts smallest
to largest you pay minimum payments on
everything but the little one you attack
the little one with the Vengeance you go
to every dollar calm you get your budget
started the first month's gonna suck the
next month's gonna suck a little less
the third month it'll start to work and
every dollar calms free yeah get your
budget going make some decisions that
your friends make fun of if you're broke
friends aren't making fun of you you're
not on track think about it all right
looks like you're doing that babe Ramsey
cult stuff yeah I'm like doing that I
don't want to be broke stuff because I
don't be a [ __ ] like you that's what
runs through your head when they say
that right this is the Dave Ramsey show
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show and so you have to break the
cycle you have to flip this thing on its
head and make it behave you've got to
get so fired up and wired up that you're
broke friends think you've lost your
mind
you